I'd like to invite you to take a seat
and I would like to introduce the third
and final panel of of the day the last
panel was was was so rich with ideas and
I'm sure we could continue discussing it
well into the evening it raised so many
questions one of them to my mind was was
how we're going to support the guild of
not investing more heavily into poverty
alleviation and affordable technologies
that solve problems people really have
around the world and I have a feeling
that that question may come up in this
next panel that sort of orientation may
come up in this next panel we have five
very interesting people they're each
going to speak for about 20 minutes and
i will not go into details I just want
to introduce them very quickly in the
order in which they'll be speaking we
begin with Erwin red-letter who is they
who is the director of the National
Center for disaster preparedness here at
Columbia and also the president of the
children's health fund will move to
Lindsay hoja who is the communications
director of sense of MIT senseable City
laboratory and no atole who was the
director of urban studies in an
assistant professor at Wheaton College
Dana Fisher who is an associate
professor of sociology here at at
Columbia and enamored shrivastava who's
the coordinator of the India Resource
Center and who I don't see it but but
we'll begin with with dr. redliner and
we have about 20 minutes per person
thank you very much good afternoon I my
role here is to make sure that if you
weren't depressed enough after Klaus
Jacobs talk that I would be the capper
and make sure you left here completely
despairing no I actually I I listened
with great interest to what Klaus had to
say about the long-term realities that
we're facing and it really what I'm
going to do is talk a little bit about
the current state of readiness
in terms of being prepared for
large-scale disasters which I call mega
disasters and I'm going to define those
in a minute but I was interested in fact
that Klaus refers to the mega cities and
i'll talk about mega disasters and so
the big question is are we are we
prepared in any in any sense of that
concept currently for large-scale
disaster so thank you very much I'll be
awesome so that's if I had really a
really short amount of time but let me
give you a little more detail it's
always fair the high price of admission
would certainly want them so before i
get into the the main perspectives on i
want to share with you i have to sort of
caveats that underpin a lot of where
we've come in terms of my center and
understanding disasters in the level of
preparedness about them the first point
is that we are not concerned that's
negative we're not concerned about the
capacity of virtually everywhere in the
united states to respond to and deal
with a small emergency or even a small
disaster it's just as we go up the scale
of impact and consequences of particular
disaster scenarios that we've become
increasingly less capable of preparing
for preventing mitigating responding to
recovering from large-scale disasters
and i wanted to spend a minute on what i
mean by mega-disaster so you understand
where i'm coming from so that the idea
behind a mega-disaster is a catastrophic
event of very high consequence no matter
what the cause whether it's terrorism or
natural events or whatever it might be
but that that catastrophe overwhelms the
local capacity or the regional response
to be able to respond effectively and
you know you are dealing with a
mega-disaster
because first of all you may and in a
nose dramatic reality of a mega-disaster
and take port-au-prince and less
january's horrible earthquake in Haiti
the inability to manage the immediate
rescue of survivors who are endangered
in the case of a big earthquake like
that there's a 72-hour window that is
medically medically legitimate period of
time where you have to get people out of
rubble if you're going to have any
chance of helping them to survive
whatever the event was after 72 hours
the fatality rates rise dramatically and
the international community basically
and entirely missed that window and this
was probably the most dramatic example
of local capacity given the condition of
Haiti before the earthquake of local
capacity being unable to do this very
basic function but this also happened in
New Orleans around Katrina it happens in
other places so the the first rule is
can you rescue people that need medical
care the second potential feature of the
mega disasters you've rescued people
you've extracted them but you don't have
the health care response capacity to
save lives to treat people that you've
now pulls from the rubble or pull you've
extracted them from the roof of their
house in New Orleans after the flooding
now you got to take them someplace to
deal with injuries and excuse me the
local health care system is incapable of
providing that vital care Third Point
and these are in priority order
obviously is the inability to protect
vital infrastructure or prevent
significant destruction of property and
material goods whether its food or the
electric grid system over the sewer
system whatever it might be that becomes
also very important if you can handle
those kinds of things locally then
you're probably not a mega-disaster
range but if it's a situation where
you're calling people and our people are
coming in from bordering states from
other regions from other countries from
the UN etc you're into mega-disaster
lamp and and finally and this is
actually extremely rare
hardly ever do we see because of a
disaster uncontrolled societal breakdown
but one might imagine that if that were
the case with a population under siege
from any kind of disaster that that
would also represent the need for
external resources to come in and assist
in dealing with whatever has to be dealt
with there so it's this mega-disaster
kind of situation that gives us the most
concern and surprisingly we're not a
whole lot better to prepare better
prepared than we were on 911 to deal
with a mega-disaster at that point and
I'm going to get into that a second the
second caveat which I've always found
very interesting is this we talk about
preparedness or getting or doing things
that make us ready for disasters but we
actually don't know what prepared means
we don't know what the definition of
that and not only don't we know what the
definition of that is for a society a
community of city we also don't happen
to know what it means for an individual
now you could say if we are abiding by
the recommendations the Red Cross or
FEMA we have three days of food and
water battery-operated radio in that
whole array of things that people
suggest that you do that you've met a
criteria for being prepared however that
set of recommendations does nothing for
you in the event of a major pandemic
where you may have to stay holed up in
your place for several weeks famously
President Bush's Secretary of Health
Human Services had this is this is no
joke nine weeks worth of tuna fish cans
under his bed this is the this is and
knowing him I it's you know sort of true
but the point I'm trying to make here is
that is that what you need or is the
three days of food and water and so
forth and what does that actually mean
it and if we can't define it as
individuals and you know we if we can't
define where we're going if we don't
know what the goal is for prepare of New
York or Madrid or Haiti for instance how
is it that we're setting benchmarks what
are we trying to accomplish how much is
it going to cost without having a goal
for what the building looks like when we
r you know when you get your building a
house you're building a skyscraper you
a cost estimate and you and you have a
process and you finally get there at you
know sometimes within the within the
range of the predicted cost but if
you're talking about getting prepared
for a city we're in some other zone
where it's very difficult but how many
of you think that you are prepared for a
mega-disaster might happen in our region
or your region wherever it might be yes
sir oh yeah yeah I almost had looked a
little arrhythmia therefore singer yes
and I by the way I've asked this
question of medical audiences of the CDC
and a lecture we gave there and any
anybody I speak to and there's hardly
any hands that go up and but to think
about what that names it extrapolate
your own experience to what you think
our public officials are actually doing
so the problem is that however we define
prepared or preparedness that it remains
true that the United States of America
and virtually every other country in the
world is not prepared for an array of
disasters which some people might
consider appropriate the UK is pretty
prepared for a lot of disasters it has
done 0 to deal with the possibility of
nuclear terrorism in London for instance
and I just spoke to the senior official
at UK about that and I said why not he
said because they don't want to all
right there you go so I'm going to talk
about some barriers that keep us from
getting prepared there's actually
probably a dozen or so that I could talk
about but but we're just going to pick
out a few that I think are most
important so first one that I want to
discuss is the this notion of the scale
and scope of planning for mega disasters
are we investing enough money for
instance in our planning process for a
very severe 1918 spanish flu like
pandemic are we preparing for a
destabilization
the seismic underpinning of New York or
the west coast for that matter where the
New Madrid Seismic vulnerability in the
middle of the country and really not and
really if it was deemed expensive before
the recession it's now deemed just
bizarrely and appropriate to even bring
to the table the amount of money for
instance that the America Society of
Civil Engineers say that just to fix the
infrastructure in the u.s. I'm sure many
of you know this is in the order of 2.7
trillion dollars now I personally if you
would ask me privately I say what a
great jobs program and we should
probably do something like that but the
fact is the appetite for large
expenditures on basically what would
amount to a life insurance policy is not
it's not in the cards anytime soon you
know it's like if you were making 150
thousand dollars a year your job
evaporated and you were unemployed for
nine months and then you get a new job
for seventy five thousand dollars a year
you may be cutting back on what you're
going to nest in the future as in
retirement planning and health insurance
I mean that disability insurance or life
insurance and I think again that is
something that it's magnified and the
same sort of thing happens in in the
planning for large-scale disasters
really the the i'm going to give you an
example of one of the things we dealt
with a few years ago when we're dealing
worried about the h5n1 that's the pre
swine flu is in the bird flu era of the
middle of this decade Governor Pataki
made an announcement of the press
release that he was going to invest 29
million dollars for New York State
pandemic avian flu planning and i wrote
a not bad about it because the fact is
we needed ten times that to get to a
level of readiness with a pandemic it's
this kind of scalar discrepancies that
have not been absorbed by officials or
people that appropriate public dollars
in no circumstance that i'm aware of is
enough money appropriated do whatever
the job is you want to see the US
hospitals for
this is prepared for large-scale
disasters it's five thousand hospitals
we originally were investing five
hundred million dollars a year spread
among those hospitals to bring them up
to some level of response capacity
that's been dropping it's now about 400
million it would actually take a five
billion dollar initial bonus and then a
billion a year to get them up someplace
now literally you have a hospital that
lets say a billy and a half dollar a
year annual budget and they're getting
eighty six thousand dollars to do
preparedness from the federal government
you know that almost pays for a nurse
that's good but the fact is that this
kind of really wildly inappropriate
absence of appropriate resources is very
very unsettling and I want to go through
some other specific example here I want
to talk about pandemic flu in New York
City to give you some more clarity about
what this point is so let's say we have
8.2 million people here in the
metropolitan area and if we had a severe
h5n1 attack of severe one then we could
expect about thirty percent of the
population to get infected now many
people who got infected would have a
mild cold some would be much sicker and
I'm going to tell you what that looks
like about ten percent of the people who
got sick so ten percent of the thirty
percent would require hospitalization
and the mortality rate is around two and
a half percent of those that get
infected would not survive that that's
that's more or less what all the models
when we talk about the impact of a
pandemic flu what they reflect for New
York City so what would happen is under
these circumstances that we'd have about
almost two and a half million New
Yorkers including 600,000 children with
some level of the flu sixty thousand
deaths including 15,000 pediatric deaths
and 200,000 hospital admissions over say
an eight week to 10 week period and and
if it was a shorter period let's say was
let's say was six or seven weeks that'd
be about three
deaths per day on average and there
would not be enough and this is
categorically true not be enough vaccine
if there was a vaccine available not
enough Tamiflu or other antiviral
medications that would not be enough
hospital beds they certainly wouldn't be
enough mechanical ventilators and so on
and so forth and then there's a whole
series of cascading events that flow
from the public health crisis that we're
facing so schools will be closed because
we don't want kids affecting one another
parents would be sick there would be
possible quarantines the economy would
be in unimaginable knots of trouble in
addition to what we have now and little
assistance from the outside because even
though be a mega zest for New York while
Chicago and Hartford and Newark are all
experiencing the same thing that's what
makes it a pandemic it's virtually
everywhere at once so extra ventilators
from another place is not going to
happen the second barrier so that's all
about this discrepancy what I just said
between resources available and what
might be needing a particular scenario
the second barrier has to do with the
the level of coordination horizontally
in in the system and regionally when it
comes to the geography of what we're
talking about here and I want to say for
a minute or two that the the
government's ability to organize a
large-scale disaster response is de- if
we're going to grade it and it depends
on the scenario it ranges from F to
maybe d+ for large-scale disasters now
I'm going to come to some question about
what we've learned from previous
experience with disasters in the US and
elsewhere for that matter and give you
some background for why why this is but
what we'll we'll get there momentarily
but I wanted to take a couple of minutes
to talk about a specific example where
the necessity for extreme amount of
planning for an extreme amount of
coordination is absolutely vital so
we're going to posit a of nuclear
terrorism I do not mean the dirty bomb
which is just a conventional explosive
emanated with some radioactive material
I'm talking about the detonation of an
atomic or other kind of nuclear weapon
similar to what was used in Hiroshima or
Nagasaki at the end of World War two and
so if we if we talk about let's say a
ten to twelve kiloton atomic weapon
that's exploded in a major city what
actually would happen now if any of you
I don't see anybody but if any of you
are over the age of 40 nope nobody you
would probably remember our collective
mindset I have a Medicare card and don't
he's sneering at me this gentleman our
collective mindset during the Cold War
was that if there was a nuclear
confrontation between the Soviet Union
and the United States is no survival and
we have nothing to talk about and that's
absolutely one hundred percent true it
was either prevention or nothing there
was no civil defense was pointless and
really was mocked as a joke by people
who knew what was going on and a lot of
physicians like myself were going around
saying hey we better prevent this we
have no medicine we have no system that
will deal with a nuclear confrontation
that mindset unfortunately has lingered
among a lot of our mergency planners
including the New York City Department
of the Office of Emergency Management
there's a very great psychological
barrier unwillingness to think about
planning for a nuclear terrorism because
they're thick and old days and that's
really quite unfortunate well so what we
have here these are the six target
cities that are considered the most
likely in the in the event that that
some organization decided they were
going to try to acquire which is
possible a nuclear weapon so San
Francisco Los Angeles Houston Chicago
Washington and New York are the places
not to be under those circumstances so
if again I'm just going to rush through
a little bit of this but a 10 kiloton
nuclear detonation in New York City
hundreds of thousands of people with
injuries would be presented by the way
if it happened in the in lower Manhattan
we right here would not be immediately
killed
or even necessarily close to being
killed we might you know there would be
windows blown out there might be some
fire started but all of us in this room
would be potential survivors if we had a
clue as to what to do when if we had
even a little bit of information from
the appropriate people in government
which we're not going to have and you're
not going to know but we'll get to that
offenders and actually the modelers from
Lawrence Livermore labs have said the
Delta between a little bit of planning
and no planning is several hundred
thousand lives lost or saved if we did a
very small amount of readiness anyway so
there are hundreds of thousands right of
casualties who need medical care here is
for this is not just New York City now
this is New York State the total number
of hospital beds is maybe 30 to 40,000
they are a lot of them obviously
occupied and a lot of those occupants of
those beds are very sick they're not
going anywhere right three minutes ago
so the discrepancy between what's
available and what might be needed is
spectacular this is part of a modeling
exercise that we did to see where New
Yorkers would go after this happened to
be a dirty bomb but you you can also do
this we have it for a nuclear detonation
and other disasters but a tremendous
chaotic evacuation at a New York City so
Goshen New York appears someplace with a
population of about 4,500 people would
find itself off the thruway exit
greeting you know fifty seventy five
hundred thousand terrified sick
potentially injured potentially
radioactive New Yorkers there's been
virtually zero planning for this chaotic
evacuation out of any city that's been
hit by a nuclear weapon third barrier is
systemic political paralysis and there
is nobody in Washington that's
responsible for nuclear response
planning there are a lot of people who
work in it there's nobody responsible
for it there's nobody who's accountable
for anything to do with this although
there's thousands of people working on
it and that's a problem there's a
hundred ten congressional committees and
subcommittees that deal with some sub
piece of Homeland Security or
clearness they do not speak to each
other they do not relinquish power and
they create silos of funding that infect
all the federal agencies and then in
turn all the state agencies so even the
possibility of coordination and
authority is zero there's nobody in the
White House that controls the people in
the various agencies that work on this
let me just come back this people I mean
you saw when I asked you to raise your
hand I don't need to dwell on this so
nobody nobody's really prepared so I
want to conclude with this point really
which is what are the lessons that we
have learned from this series of events
that this is just a few of the things
that you know we're all familiar with
and each one of these should have been
learning opportunities so that we are
more prepared for whatever it is the
next time and almost none of the lessons
that should have come out of these these
events have actually been absorbed so
we're still fooling around with how
we're going to do biosurveillance means
technology in places like post offices
and train stations where we can early
detect a biological agent that's they're
still rudimentary still not solve the
interoperability of radios that was a
problem killing several hundred
firefighters in New York on 911 the
technologies they are still not
implemented you know all these years
later smallpox the whole other story
which is you know we had to probably
don't remember the summer of two
thousand two there was a plan by the
government to inoculate the country
against smallpox because we're afraid
that the Iraqis would send infected
smallpox infected agents here to create
a epidemic and so forth but TNT TMT see
about the lessons from Katrina you know
if you're looking at a slide and then
your analysis let's say you want to know
are there a lot of white cells
indicating an infection if there's so
many there that's dealing but you can't
even count them say too numerous to
count TNT Z so the reference here is
that there are so many lessons not
learned at a Katrina that I would have
to spend another couple hours here in
Iwo lemon and Haiti
I'm not gonna even dwell on them so the
question these things which are often
referred to as wake up calls do in fact
prompt us to do things will create a
Department of Homeland Security will
spend a little money and then we've
become complacent and we forget about it
and we don't absorb the lessons and so
although it's called a wake-up call
they're really more like snooze alarms
we get aroused we kind whatever we do is
shake ourselves off we hit the button
and we drift back to sleep everybody
okay yeah good luck to ya I'm going back
to my shelter you one might
hello everyone i'm here from sensible
cities lab which is a research lab at
MIT we're a fairly small lab or
comprised of about 30 people right now
our researchers come from various
disciplines in computer science
engineering graphic design architecture
what we do is we use technologies that
are often pioneered MIT and we look at
cities across the globe that are having
current problems and we try to figure
out weeds we can use the technologies
developed to MIT to help solve some of
these problems we often bring in big
industry leaders like Cisco IBM and
Intel to address some of these issues
but first I want to talk about cities
and where they're headed
okay yep ok so in 1990 in the late 1990s
when the internet was becoming more
ubiquitous it was becoming more widely
available to the public a lot of
Technology writers and technologists
predicted the death of cities so okay
this is a quote from George Gilder he's
the founder of the Discovery Institute
and he's a technology writer he said
we're headed towards the death of cities
their leftover baggage from the
industrial era a lot of people thought
at the time that because digital spaces
were becoming more widespread and more
complex that physical spaces would cease
to have an importance that they once
held in our lives what we found this is
not true at all actually at the
beginning of the 21st century we've
found that for the first time ever there
was a momentous but invisible shift
where half the world's population now
live in urban areas and that number is
only expected to increase over the next
10 15 30 to 50 years so MIT were trying
to figure out what's this mean what does
this mean for architecture for urban
planning for engineering how can we use
the technologies that we're working on
to improve the places where we live work
and play how can we embed networks and
sensors in a very sort of seamless way
to improve the quality of life across
the board we're looking also very
specifically at environmental issues
which is I'm going to talk about today
environmentally really related problems
that we're trying to solve so I'm going
to talk today specifically about two
projects that our lab is working on
we're working on several in the last six
years since our lab was developed I
think we've worked on over 30 different
projects and these are just the most
relevant so sensible cities work
scouring urban futures by developing
technologically different projects to
solve some of today's most pressing
environmental issues so this is trash
track this was one of our most famous
projects it was widely covered at the
time by BBC Wired magazine the Boston
Globe and what we tried to do is we took
this idea of smart dust smart dust I'm
not sure if you know but it's
nanotechnology they're small micro
sensors that can communicate wirelessly
with each other it's still an idea but
we wanted to take this idea how can we
have little bits of micro information
floating in the environment that could
communicate with each other and
communicate back to us and tell us about
the ambient environment we thought about
this and we wanted to apply it to a real
world problem or real world challenge
and one of those problems is garbage
garbage is becoming an increasingly
important issue especially in terms of
the environment I don't know if any of
you if I read about the great pacific
garbage patch which is located between
california and hawaii but it's a
floating massive trash that's over twice
the size of Texas researchers have
predicted yeah it's a it's pretty
shocking researchers have predicted that
they're you know they estimate that
there are five total garbage patches
they collect in them swirling currents
in the world's oceans so we focus
specifically on land-based trash but you
can see from this visualization from
this picture that it's a it's a huge and
it's a growing problem so one of the
problems is that we know so much about
the supply chain but we know so little
about their mythical chain if you take a
standard computer for example you can
break down the individual parts and find
out where each component came from this
is something we did with a MacBook Pro
we had staff at the Media Lab take apart
a computer and using the tracking
numbers they could find out where
different pieces were where they came
from all over the world where it was
shipped where it was put together and we
sort of have a sense that these things
are being disposed of properly but we
often know that they're not especially
with regard to electronic waste
computers TV monitors are often disposed
they're shipped overseas on big
container ships and their dumped in
third world countries like India and
Pakistan where they're not properly
treated at all you can see that from a
picture here so what our idea was we
wanted to embed wireless devices into
trash that was going to be step one we
wanted to them to be sort of invisible
so that if someone came across the trash
they wouldn't realize what was inside of
it we had traceable garbage in the urban
environment that was sort of the idea we
would be able to follow it with the
average
the holder wouldn't know where it was
going waste management would come by and
would collect the material it would be
transported and it could be taken to any
number of places it could be shipped it
could be dumped it could be incinerated
may be recycled a number stick sort of
illustrates what we were trying to get
at where do these things actually end up
we had no idea and one thing I should
stay here the tags that we developed
were all monitored the level of toxins
in them was safe to be put into a
landfill or to be incinerated it was
below the US governmental regulations so
this is one of the first trash tags that
we developed it relied on gsm technology
it was able to communicate to the
nearest cell phone tower tower so we
could have sort of a rough estimate of
where it was located these are a series
of the tags we sealed them in plastic
and we number each one this project was
done in partnership with waste
management and eventually was done in
partnership with qualcomm so you see the
little phone like material in this
person's hand that's actually a trash
tag it works very similarly to a cell
phone it sends out text messages to us
based on location so it can't make phone
calls but it can send us messages so we
know exactly where it is is at a given
time if it's not moving for a certain
amount of time it's programmed at
certain intervals every two to three
hours to tell us its location so what
partner the period of time that we could
use them these had a lifespan of about
three months and then the batteries died
off so these are the tags a wrapped in
sort of a film material so they were
water resistant but they weren't
waterproof what we did is we partnered
with this city of Seattle Seattle has
some of the most innovative and
progressive recycling programs in the
country so we partnered with them this
is a photo taken outside the Seattle
Public Library we had 500 volunteers
from Seattle volunteer to have their
trash tagged I'm created a wishlist so
we wanted items that were not just
household items but we wanted electronic
waste we wanted to make sure that we had
a variety so you can see here at
Jennifer denim who's one of
our researchers and an architecture
student in our lab she is tagging some
trash brought by some volunteers this is
a soft Federman he his dumb disco said
director of our lab he's cutting open a
teddy bear to put inside one of the tags
here are some more pictures of things so
we had everything from television sets
to motor oil containers to soup bowls
and what you notice in most of these
pictures is that you can't actually see
the tag as I mentioned before that was
intentional we wanted them to be picked
up by waste management and not noticed
as they went through the waste removal
stream and this is a test run we did in
Cambridge so the dots that you see that
is the place where the trash originated
from and the lines going out is where
the trash traveled over several hours we
also partnered up with google so that
all the volunteers had an individual
number that they could go in and enter
online so they could follow their piece
or pieces of trash individually to syrah
ended up so here's an example this is a
yogurt container this was actually done
in Seattle and you can see that in three
days it's traveled around 35 miles
starts at the top all the dots that you
see along the way indicate points where
the object was stationary the larger the
dot the longer it was stationary so and
this is some initial data that our
researchers have just collected we're
just now going through this project was
launched last year and we're just now
able to analyze all the data if you take
photos of this please don't release this
we're working on a paper writing
actually and we're still in contact with
waste management we have a video of
visualization that I can't show but this
is just a very close-up picture of the
City of Seattle you can see different
traces I think this is after only a
couple hours but what you end up seeing
after several days and several weeks is
it some of these materials travel all
the way across the country sometimes as
far as far as Washington DC or Florida
what we found out is that things that
are most likely to stay close to the
source are things that are easy to
recycle like paper
our plastics aluminum because most
cities have proper recycling facilities
for those the items that traveled the
farthest were electronic waste because
it wasn't economically efficient often
for cities to have their own facilities
it was much easier for them to ship them
all the way across the country even
though the environmental footprint might
have been much greater ok so that was
trash track we'll have a paper
forthcoming hopefully in the next couple
months so C swarm is a project that we
did this summer says Venice 2010 because
we were invited by the the biennale in
Venice to present and vision for life in
2050 using nanotechnology so how will we
live our lives in 2050 how will
nanotechnology improve the way we live
so we thought of this idea and obviously
this summer one of the big issues on our
minds was the oil spill in the Gulf we
did some background research and found
out that over 800 800 skimmers were
deployed to clean up just the surface
oil from the spill there are lots of
different types of skimmers most them
needed some form of human intervention
they're due to difficulty of scalability
and operation only three percent of all
circle employed was actually collected
to date and that's a very generous
estimate some estimates are as low as
one percent so we are also working with
a professor MIT called francesco de la
chi he has recently developed and he's
in the process of patenting a nano
fabric it's a nano technology that's
able to selectively absorb oil from
water so its hydrophobic you can put the
material in water and it will only
absorb oils you can see on the lower
right hand side there's a layer of
gasoline and the fabric is put into the
water it comes back out completely dry
it won't absorb any water the article
discussing this fabric is mentioned in
nature nanotechnology so here's a
close-up of the fabric it looks and
feels like paper so it's a very very
fine mesh
one of the exciting things about this
material as well as it's up to absorb
its able to absorb up to 20 times its
weight in oil and it's we have a
constant removal process so once it's
burned if the materials burned off from
the mesh fabric it could be used over
and over and over again so we took this
idea and we thought what if we could
design of lead us a feat of small
autonomous scalable robots that could
utilize the standout fabric to clean up
future oil spills this is a breakdown of
what the vehicle would look like we're
currently calling it C swarm it's
inspired by a catamaran so there's a
yellow head at the top sort of
stabilizes it in the front you see a
conveyor belt it's covered by the thin
nano fabric and as it moves through the
head the head keeps up the fabric to an
extent where the oil is either burned
off or it's collected and then the
fabric is able to be used over and over
again we made the belt flexible so it's
able to conform to the shape of the
water it's slip resistant in this way
it's very flexible these are the options
i meant before so it has several options
we can either burn off the oil this is
one of the options we're looking to we
can bag it in plastic bags and leave a
tracking tags so that larger ships would
be able to come by and pick it up or we
might be able to shed the oil and store
it on site in the head that would
obviously involve scaling up this
prototype the prototype we've developed
right now is about two meters by five
meters so it's a half-scale prototype we
would need to make it much bigger so the
way that it works is it works on swarm
behavior using Wi-Fi these units are
able to communicate to each other their
autonomous use a sensing system there's
no human intervention necessary or
involved in any way so they'll be able
to communicate with each other and be
able to work completely autonomously
this is the first-generation prototype
that we tested at MIT you can see it's
in one of the water tanks we have here
at the lab
so this is built just using materials
that we got at a local hardware store
and a Walmart I think we put this
together in a couple weeks just to be
able to see if the conveyor belt would
work if it could propel itself if it
could control its movement this is the
second generation prototype you can see
the head is much bigger the plastic
piece in the middle is designed to catch
the conveyor belt as it moves through
this is the final version and this is
the version that we showed at the Venice
Biennale you can see the in the front
the Nano fabric-covered conveyor belt
that moves through also one thing I
should mention is the way that it's
powered is through photovoltaics so on
the top of the head has a series of
photovoltaic cells that will be able to
keep it running for several months our
researchers have done some estimates and
they believe that if we had five to ten
thousand of these vehicles working
twenty-four/seven for several months we
would be able to clean up oil spill the
size of the Gulf we tested it in the
Charles River a few weeks ago it works
we've gotten a lot of press for this
it's been doing really well right now
we're focusing most of our efforts on
entering it into the wendy schmidt oil
prize it's a 1.4 million dollar x prize
for anyone who can come up with a new
technology that are more quickly and
efficiently address future oil spills to
date we haven't had a chance to test it
in the Gulf we're assembling a new team
of engineers that'll hopefully be able
to go there within the next couple
months to actually test this out it's
only had one actual run in the water so
far and it's that's it these are some of
our projects
can we have the lights on I don't have a
PowerPoint presentation today I know can
you believe it yeah a couple of years
ago I was at a conference and the
colleague of mine asked me if I was
going to be using PowerPoint i said no i
was going to be power pointless and at
the time I had not anticipated all the
different meanings of that one of them
being that's going without power point
the other one being that PowerPoint
perhaps encourages sometimes especially
among my students a certain you know
pointless kind of presentation culture
and the third one being that I was going
to have no point and so hopefully I had
a point that day and hopefully have a
point today too even though I don't have
slides it's a pleasure and an honor to
be here today and before I begin I'd
like to thank dr. saason for the
invitation to join what's proven to be
an important conference on a topic of
pressing global concern my own
contribution to the day's deliberations
concerns the role of municipalities and
transnational municipal networks in
global climate governance the matter of
cities and climate change concerns not
only what we might call the centripetal
aspect of local global relations to
borrow a physics-based metaphor both
from dr. sawsan and from our june
appadurai but also the centrifugal
aspect of those relations that is it
concerns not only those emergent
conditions of the urban landscape shaped
by global environmental change and
efforts to govern the same it also
concerns the potential for urban actors
from formally authoritative
municipalities to informally
authoritative actors in the air in the
urban landscape to shape both the global
environment and principles and practices
by which we govern global environmental
change in other words when considering
the relationship between cities in the
global environment we need to consider
to stick with the physics metaphor here
both what the world spins into cities
and what cities spin into the world the
question before me is how to
characterize
primarily the centrifugal role of
transnational municipal networks in
climate governance how might we best
frame and compare the formation and
actions of various transnational
municipal networks and their
contributions to global climate
governance I propose that the roles of
transnational municipal networks become
clearer when we frame them as involved
in either governance oriented technical
entrepreneurship or politics oriented
norm entrepreneurship the former i'll
suggest corresponds to what we might
call normal environmental politics while
the latter corresponds to what we might
call post normal environmental politics
this post normal expression of
environmental politics by municipalities
and transnational municipal networks has
the potential to begin as dr. sausan has
put it to change the orientation or
valence of cities as systems the
capabilities of which have significant
extraterritorial reach for the sake of
illustrating this point and because
transnational municipal networks are
only now beginning to devote attention
to adaptation I will focus on the matter
of transnational municipal networks and
climate mitigation climate change
mitigation specifically I'll speak of
emissions reduction targets or
strategies rather than strategies for
greenhouse gas sequestration much of the
literature on transnational municipal
climate governance networks concerns
either their effectiveness or the
reasons that municipalities join these
networks regarding the former many
scholars find both municipalities and
transnational municipal networks
unlikely to be especially effective
actors and Climate stabilization while
municipalities possess not
inconsiderable policy and planning
instruments that can contribute to local
emissions reductions the mobility of
producers and consumers their capacities
to move beyond the jurisdictions of
these municipalities means that federal
or at least coordinated action would be
required in order to make globally
meaningful emissions
reductions transnational municipal
network membership is not broad enough
to achieve this level of coordination
yet regarding the rationale for
municipal membership reasons that cities
join these networks range from the
exceptional vulnerability of cities
we've heard about that today to some
projected effects of climate change to
the presence of progressive governance
regimes in some cities these would be
Gregg's Crusaders if there are any to
eco branding or greenwashing perhaps
Gregg's cynics unfortunately none of
this excellent research tells us what
role these networks might play in a
governance environment that due to the
stunted development of mega multilateral
efforts at Climate stabilization is
increasingly characterized by
multicentric and multi-level efforts
that include what Matthew Hoffman has
called climate governance experiments in
a forthcoming book from Oxford
University Press Hoffman argues that
actors from the individual to the
organizational level have been engaging
in climate governance characterized by
voluntary membership binding agreement
to undertake certain actions and market
orientation much of what goes under the
name of transnational municipal networks
is consistent with Hoffman's climate
climate experiment idea the largest and
most prominent transnational municipal
networks participating in climate
governance could fairly be characterized
in this fashion no such network is
bigger than the international council
for local environmental initiatives
cities for climate protection program
Italy itself boasts more than 1,000
member municipalities in over 60
countries and the climate protection
program has hundreds of municipal
members that have signed on to equities
five milestone program for baselining
greenhouse gas emissions developing a
climate change action plan assessing the
implementation of those plans and
finally taking steps to reduce emissions
Italy sheer size and organization make
it a formidable actor in multi-level
climate governance it was the first
network of local
governments to become an accredited
observer organization at the UNFCCC it
is a founding partner in the world
climate summit and has been instrumental
in the development of the carb on city's
climate registry an institution of
accountability for municipalities that
pledged to undertake the type of program
that ccp has promoted equally ccp not
only organizes urban Climate
stabilization efforts but it diffuses
best practices for Climate stabilization
across cities and if evidence of
vertical policy diffusion is to be
believed from cities to state and
national levels of governance another
high-profile municipal network is the
c40 large cities climate leadership
group a group of the world's leading
cities committed to tackling climate
change c40 is primarily a network of
municipalities that share information
about urban policy initiatives
particularly fitting to large cities
that seek to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions c40 cities have pledged in
particular to undertake policies and
elite alliances to accelerate the uptake
of climate friendly technologies and
influence the marketplace in eight key
areas buildings energy lighting ports
renewable energy transport heat on
transport waste and water what is it
that network such as equally CCP and c40
are up to then what are they diffusing
into the domain of global climate
governance both organizations are
diffusing best practices and information
to keys to technical entrepreneurship as
technical entrepreneurs both equally CCP
and c40 are legitimizing forces of and
in global environmental governance
pioneering problem-solving activities in
which actors are among the first to
engage a particular environmental
challenge or to engage it with unique
methods but in any case to engage it and
who gave that challenge within the
bounds of established and widely
accepted norms and values one might
describe these efforts at technical
entrepreneurship as normal environmental
politics to borrow akan
from thomas kuhn ccp and c40 are
involved in problem solving or puzzle
solving activities the practice of
normal environmental politics is one
that pursues climate stability in the
context of political economic stability
serving to legitimize the norms and
values undergirding the extant system of
climate governance even while admitting
that that system suffers from technical
failures the failure to undertake
serious and effective Climate
stabilization efforts at the national
and multilateral levers levels is
regarded as a puzzle to be solved within
the bounds of prevailing political and
economic theories and hypotheses there
is however an alternative sticking with
kun momentarily if some municipalities
and transnational municipal networks are
involved in normal environmental
politics then others may be involved in
what we could call post normal
environmental politics rather than
seeing climate change and the inability
to establish a global regime for the
stabilization of climate as mere puzzles
in an otherwise robust paradigm for
global environmental governance some
might see climate change and the
inability to establish a global regime
for the stabilization of climate as
anomalies that reveal serious flaws in
the constellation of values principles
and norms that constitute our paradigm
of global environmental governance post
normal climate politics would call into
question the values principles and norms
that constitute this paradigm and engage
in the search for Climate stabilization
solutions founded upon or consistent
with alternative values principles and
norms it is a relatively straightforward
task to imagine what such an effort
might look like calling into question
the signal value of market-based
environmental governance namely
efficiency not calling it into question
because it is one foundation of
market-based environmental governance
but because it isn't under examined and
under under deliberated norm and serves
as part of the architecture of the
global environmental governance
that has failed to articulate a regime
for climate stability post normal
environmental politics would evidence a
sort of fishing around for suitable
norms upon which to base a more
effective approach to Climate
stabilization transnational municipal
networks participating in such an
endeavor would Express these norms in
ways that shape the outcomes of their
work at least one transnational
municipal network proves to be involved
in post normal environmental politics
the International solar cities
initiative or iski is an organization
that hosts biennial SolarCity congresses
for cities committed to an equitable and
sustainable climate stability solution
it was founded in 2003 when 19 mayor's
signed the Daegu declaration at the
first SolarCity's Congress in Daegu
Korea South Korea the Daegu declaration
elevates the norms of sustainability and
equity over the norm of efficiency
calling for cities to pledge to meet the
annual per capita emissions goal of 3.3
tons of co2 equivalent greenhouse gases
which was at the time regarded by some
as an emissions rate that might
stabilize atmospheric concentrations of
greenhouse gases at sustainable levels
the per capita aspect of this target
coupled with s keys focus on the
municipal scale expresses and privileges
the norm of equity a norm that is
largely absent from the mainstream of
global climate governance deliberations
or at least not operationalized in this
particular fashion in the first place
per capita expressions of emissions
targets at any scale below the global
scale ensure an equity between even if
not within different nations or
communities that is the higher the scale
for which the target is expressed the
greater the potential for disparities
and inequities hypothetically and at the
extreme in a world of 7 billion people
23 billion tons per year could be
emitted by one person while 100 million
tonnes could be emitted collectively by
all 6 billion
999 million 999999 people by expressing
this cap as a target at the national
scale though we immediately multiplied
the minimum level of equity by multiple
orders of magnitude specifically 203 the
number of sovereign nation states
worldwide we also increase the proximity
of those who emit the most gases to
those whom it the least by expressing
this cap is a target at the municipal
scale we decrease inequality thousands
of times over further increasing minimum
levels of equity by multiple orders of
magnitude while further increasing the
proximity of those who emit the most
gases to those who emit the least taking
advantage of what dr. sausan is called
the production of presence in cities
this is a far cry from the singular
focus on the efficient distribution of
scarce resources as the norming norm of
global environmental governance that is
the norm that norms all other norms the
the relationship between urban and
global environmental politics is
evidently mutually constitutive
industrial and post-industrial urban
metabolisms shape the global environment
in particular ways aside from which
global climate governance would be a
moot issue on the other hand the
politics of this hitherto largely
multilateral environmental governance
issue is being instantiated both within
and between cities and transnational
municipal networks at the same time
those cities and municipal network
shaped global climate politics in the
case of networks participating in normal
environmental politics networks like
Italy CCP or c40 they are defusing best
practices both horizontally across
cities and vertically to actors at other
scales in the case of networks
participating in post normal
environmental politics they are defusing
values principles and norms in other
words transnational municipal networks
may play the role of norm entrepreneur
and global environmental politics
specifically they may introduce or
articulate norms that are
subversive in the sense that Cardinal
arms of south polo uses the word to
subvert he says means to turn a
situation round and look at it from the
other side that is the side of the
people who have to die so that the
system can go on the International
SolarCity's initiative like some other
actors in global climate governance for
example the alliance of small island
states and others whose lives and
livelihoods are at stake understands and
articulates the climate governance
imperative and the role of cities and
climate governance as an issue of
environmental justice of the inequitable
distribution of environmental risk and
the lack of participation in determining
environmental quality let me be clear
about what I'm not saying I'm not saying
that transnational municipal networks
will necessarily introduce or articulate
norms that will eventually be
operationalized in mainstream global
climate governance the eventual adoption
and operationalization of norms advanced
is not the measure of a norm
entrepreneur still even norms that are
not adopted and operationalized may play
an important role in governance the
introduction and articulation of even
marginal norms may shape the ways in
which more mainstream norms are
operationalized in this way even if
cities and transnational municipal
networks are not especially effective at
or key actors in the achievement of
Climate stabilization they may find
themselves effective in shaping the way
we govern climate change the most
important role of transnational
municipal networks may in fact be that
of norm entrepreneur in the mode of post
normal environmental politics thank
alright I'm going to ask please do not
turn off the lights everybody can see
and it just reinforces the idea that
it's a meat locker in here so please so
I'm going to go next to be the person
who has to be PowerPoint less or maybe
i'm being power pointed so you judge by
how my talk goes okay so um hi I'm Dana
Fisher and i am here to talk about
environmental activism in the urban
ecosystem let me just say that the talk
is based on preliminary findings from
two different projects I'm working on
their funded by the National Science
Foundation and i'm calling from pieces
that are from different articles as well
as a piece that's worth coming in the
encyclopedia of globalization so if
anybody's interested in something I talk
about today feel free to ask me because
I have a number of papers that I'm
speaking from so it's like that's right
okay so what is environmental activism
here is a definition that I put together
this is from my piece in the
encyclopedia of globalization it is
defined as collective social action that
is focused on issues related to the
natural environment and it's interesting
when I was given the task of writing
this piece I spoke with my colleague
sottero and I said to him how have you
guys defined and he says oh no come up
with something good so hopefully you'll
feel that that is a good definition um
unless it's a working definition and one
of the things that I think is very
important here is to make this broad
enough that it includes a diversity of
actors so we have civil society working
by themselves as civil society actors
grassroots activists but then we also
have these hybrid formations of groups
working with businesses and government
elites in ways that have become
increasingly increasingly prevalent
within different types of regimes and
different types of environmental issues
and such action can be in support of the
protection of environmental goods and we
can think about protecting a coral reef
or a virgin forest but they also can be
in opposition so in protest of the
distribution of environmental Bad's so
good examples of this would be
protesting toxic waste that is being
release during industrial processes or
even the siting of garbage landfills and
specific communities the important thing
here as you can see in my little arrow
is that there are two sides there's this
continuum here and there are a range of
tactics and a range of targets that come
out of environmental activists and based
on what the targets and tactics are
environmental activism has different
phases and and in a lot of cases
increasingly the environmental activism
targets actors at multiple scales of
governance simultaneously and what I'm
going to do you know in my work I look
at this in multiple types of
environmental issues but here today what
I'm going to do is provide two examples
that show that first of all there's a
diversity of ways that Marmol activism
takes place but second of all to show
that environmental activism even though
there are multiple scales at which it
takes place it is extremely
geographically situated and i'll
hopefully prove that to today so i'm
going to present two examples of
environmental activism that would I
wouldn't say are on the extreme points
with regard to this arrow but definitely
fall on the two sides of the arrow and
the first one is going to be looking at
a relatively supportive case of
environmental activities specifically
here in New York City with in relation
to the sustainability plan in New York
City and then the second one involves
much more oppositional tactics and
targets and activities having to do with
the climate change regime in Copenhagen
during the climate change negotiations
last winter so cop15 for all of you who
do work on climate so case one start
right here in New York City here's New
York City it's a much nicer looking day
on all these pictures than it is today
so this this work comes out of the work
I've been doing with the u.s. Forest
Service for a number of years and it's
part of our stewardship mapping and
assessment project or what we like to
call Stu map and we've been working on
the project since to south 2005 and what
this project started with was a survey
of all civic groups doing stewardship in
New York City so within the bounds of
New York City and I should just tell you
how we define Stu
werd ship so that there are no questions
here it is defined as anybody or any
group and it has to be a group so it has
to be more than one person that engages
in a component of stewardship as defined
as conserving managing monitoring
advocating for and educating friends
neighbors and representatives about the
local environments and this includes
water land air waste toxic sentient
energy uses as you may understand here
this is an extremely broad way of
thinking about stewardship or
environmental activism and the point
here is that there are lots of people
and organizations that do work having to
do with the environment that wouldn't
self-identify as environmental activists
but they're still doing work that would
fall into my definition of let's see I
should have that memorized collective
social action focused on issues related
to the natural environment so to begin
with let me give you a map here's an
organizational density map of the
organizations that are responded to our
survey so that n is 555 groups in New
York City it comes out of a survey of
2793 groups so we have a response rate
about twenty percent which is consistent
but not as good as we would have loved
but you get a sense here of how plays
out across the five boroughs next here
is our response to how do they Stuart so
how do they actually do stuff with
regard to the environment so respondents
were allowed to check all that apply
here and the percentages are based on
those who answer these questions so you
see conservation is the most dominant
then we go down to education advocating
men and managing and then monitoring
falls down below
this next diagram shows you where they
steward so this builds off of um earlier
work on an exhaustive way that urban
stewards may participate in the kinds of
areas and site types where they may
actually take care of the environment so
we run the gamut from parks all the way
down to dog runs and basically groups
reported working all different types of
sites around New York City the most
common sites were parks community
gardens and street trees so those are
the trees that line the streets not the
trees there in the parks and the least
common sites were stewardship for
rooftops with which may be becoming much
more popular right now because there's a
big green roof movement here in New York
City I'm and dog runs which you know
mostly involve scooping poop so a lot of
people don't choose to do it I'm just
being honest here right okay one of the
other things that we've been doing with
this project and what these data are
looking at the connections among the
stewarts now I realize that this is
probably completely illegible but what I
wanted you to do is get a sense of the
map of the connections among this George
so we asked the group's how they connect
with one another and with whom they
connect and this is everybody all of the
civic groups and it doesn't talk about
how they connect with businesses or
government groups or government agencies
but we do have that as well and here's
what I want you to take away from this
very hard to read map the first thing is
that there's a big collection and claw
maury shin of ISIL it's in the middle
groups that really aren't connected too
much at all and they're relatively
disconnected and they tend to be rather
tend to be the smaller groups and then
on the outside we have the ring of
connected groups and the size here
represents the number of groups I
mentioned them right so we have probably
the most popular here
so you get a sense and one of the things
that's interesting and if I had more
time to talk I tell you about this is
that the groups tend to UM along
together with groups that focus on the
same types of environmental issues right
so the water groups are with the water
groups and the land groups tend to be
connected to the land groups and we're
digging much more into these data now so
that's what I can tell you at this point
but stay tuned if you're interested so
we're currently looking into the
characteristics of the network broadly
as well as the hybrid arrangements which
I'm very interested in terms of how the
groups are working with businesses as
well as government actors and then we're
also doing an organizational history of
the nodes and that's part of the work
that I'm doing with the the ultra X
project that I leave here in New York
City so that gives you a little sense of
what's going on here in New York City
here's a very very different case but
I'm going to argue is certainly
geographically situated this is the case
of the climate movement now the climate
movement can be discussed in all
different ways is the global movement is
connected between transnational actors
some would argue actually that the
groups that you were talking about these
municipal municipalities are actually
part of the climate movement but we'll
just put them aside for now and just say
that I'm talking about the actors who
were involved specifically in climate
activists I'm around the climate
negotiations in Copenhagen in december
two thousand nine that was during the
the cop15 negotiations and here are some
pictures some of which i took the blurry
ones and some which i didn't take like
this one I wasn't that close to the guy
beating up the protester and what I
think is very important to note here is
that there were many different ways of
doing activism in Copenhagen okay we've
got outside the negotiations and outside
the negotiations involved marching this
is the huge March it involve 80,000
people it also involved a lot of billy
clubs and a little bit of teargas and
then there was an activism taking place
inside the negotiations and that's where
there were a lot of NGO observers and
researchers presenting their work trying
to speak to the regime more broadly and
then you have you know the carol is who
anybody at any any of us who have
actually been the climate negotiations
know you always have the carolers and
they sing these wonderful songs that
have been rewritten to be about
destroying the planet and eventually the
pan that shows
or no sorry the Koala the Panda shows up
to I had another picture pan but this is
the Koala and he sits there and you know
and that's that's environmental activism
right so both of these kinds of tactics
were used in Copenhagen and they used in
all of the climate all the times that
climate activism takes place around the
meanings of these the climate regime but
what I think is kind of interesting
about what happened in Copenhagen is
that was extremely elevated okay so this
is just a table that shows you civil
society participation inside the
negotiations starting on with cop six
the negotiations where the the Kyoto
Protocol was supposed to be finished and
we can talk at length about that but
just to give you a sense of
participation right so you can see here
that the total number of NGO observers
from 2000-2009 went from you know 3,500
people to 20,000 611 people right within
the negotiations just going in to do
stall and in a lot of ways I think this
is a proxy for the type of the level of
environmental activism that was taking
place within the hall now there's a
whole discussion about what happened the
bella center in the second half of the
negotiations that i'll just table but if
anybody's interested i have a paper on
it I'd be happy to share with you but
outside at the same time there was this
huge first of all there was a huge day
of action that took place where there
were 80 thousand people who own
protested and that was connected to a
global day of action that coordinated
actions in 180 countries so let me give
you a sense of environmental activism
outside so this is based on a random
survey of protesters that I did with a
bunch of students during the
demonstration in march in copenhagen on
a big saturday in between the two weeks
of negotiation and it's just you know a
diagram to show you where everybody came
from and i'm just starting to play with
these data now so this is probably the
best i was able to show you here but
basically what you can see here is that
people came from all over although we
got a lot of europe she's not surprising
because if you're going to travel
somewhere to participate in activism it
frequently ends up that you go
relatively close to home but we had a
nice diversity of people sampled in in
the survey and denmark represented the
largest turnout and there were unions
are having been in the crowd freezing my
fingers off i can tell you that denmark
had the largest number of people
had unions out they had groups
specifically from Copenhagen they had
moms out with their families who want to
get their kids out to show him what
activism was all about so it was a
really interesting diversity of people
one of the other things that we did is I
worked with a computer scientists at
Rutgers and we kept track of tweets
taking place around the climate climate
activism in Copenhagen so this is
actually these are these are newly on
analyze data is Israel in the crown he
said he was coming so I had this
wonderful student who I went to get my
props do who analyzed these data we had
1049 tweets that took place around
specifically talking about activism in
the police in Copenhagen during the
two-week period that was the
negotiations and what we did is we coded
them doing a Content analysis to look at
what people were talking about because
one of the things that happened is there
was all this direct action taking place
and so the police were trying to
infiltrate so they would go to the bars
and the hostels where the activists were
staying and try to shut them down so
they couldn't come out and storm the
bella center which was what their goal
was and their their aim was on the
wednesday of the beginning of the
ministerial meeting they would shut down
the negotiations so I was very
interested in how tweed tweeting was
related to what was happening in the
streets so what you see here is that um
the activists were using Twitter right
so they tweeted a lot about police
activity but one thing that I thought
was very interesting as I expected that
a lot of the tweets would be about
planning to meet places so you know
we're going to go throw rocks at this
you know this location join us and it
ends up that you can barely see there's
this little um mom plum band that's in
there that is the planning but most of
it was about reporting and and looking
at how people were just reporting on
activities that we're taking place so I
think this is you know an interesting
way of thinking about how activists you
know all these people talk about how
activists are using the internet and new
technologies and here's an opportunity
to start thinking about a time when they
really had to use it because people were
getting locked up in jailed and all of a
sudden this was a wonderful tool for
them for coordinating and identifying
things like the police have surrounded
the bar don't come here for our meeting
but these were the kinds of these are
the kinds of things that people were
tweeting about so this gives you a sense
of how it happened and what I think is
really interesting is this is the day
this is the day they tried to shut down
the negotiations in lo and behold as one
might expect that's when most tweeting
happened alright so moving on success
and failure of environmental activism in
Copenhagen so this is based on a paper
I'd published in global environmental
politics which talks about what i call
the merging of movements so we have
historically this traditional movement
is climate movement of environmental
groups and NGO observers that try to
participate and influence what's going
on within the negotiations and those
include the carolers and the koala bears
and pandas and you know you always have
the vegans there and they hand out you
know weird rotten sandwiches with meat
and them and tasteful things like that
and at the same time you also had this
climate justice movement that wanted to
use direct action and work outside the
negotiations and for the first time you
had people coming specifically the
negotiations with no interest whatsoever
in getting in except for to shut down
what was happening inside and you had a
little bit of that taking place in
earlier negotiations but not to the same
degree and what I say in the paper is
that specifically this merging of
movements led to civil society being
left out in the cold and I mean this
actually quite literally because those
of us who were there and all researchers
counted civil society by the way because
we're not members of a state delegations
we're standing out in the cold I stood
out the cold for eight hours the last
that I went into the negotiations
because the registration lines were so
long and they were basically trying to
keep keep people out because they didn't
want there to be activists and taking
place inside and they started to worry
for the government representatives who
were inside the other thing that this
did is it really increased the you know
the visibility of what was happening and
also I would argue led to a different
type of activism that will take place at
climate negotiations in the future it's
kind of like what we've seen during the
for the WTO for the World Bank for what
happens in Davos so we'll see if that's
true and Cancun is coming but I know
Cancun does a really good job with
security so we'll see so a
conclusion here my take-home messages so
first of all environmental activism is
very diverse and involve multiple actors
who target all scales of governance
through a variety of tactics and there
some of them are more or less
oppositional depending on what their
targets are and there goes our we need
to understand better how different forms
of environmental activism and the actors
involved are related and try to
understand how they work together and
how sometimes they don't work together
in addition to the more abstract
understanding that this will help us to
do you know for those of us who you know
who write in you know abstracts you know
sociological journals that you'll
probably never read there also will be
very helpful for us to understand the
effectiveness and civil society's role
in policy making processes better and
this isn't just at the multinational
level this is also at local skills of
governance where civil society actors
engage in many different ways and also
you know in many ways that's where they
really take care of the environment they
don't do a lot of taking care of the
environment if they're flying to another
country to participate in global
activism that the real environmental
activism I would argue takes place in
places outside your front door and when
you are constantly being involved in
environmental management of sample so
thank you very much
I would like to introduce our concluding
speaker he will be the last one ameet
thiruvalla if I pronounced that right
has been an activist and really an
inventor of new strategies I am a great
admirer of the project he Amit initiated
the climate justice initiative in 2000
which was the first ever program on
climate justice which redefined climate
change from a human rights and
environmental justice perspective but
today he is the coordinator of India
Resource Center and the director of
global resistance for the last eight
years Amit has coordinated the
international campaign to hold coca-cola
accountable for mismanagement of water
resources in India and I think that is
what you're going to talk a bit about
right thank you and how is everybody
doing good I know power point here is a
perspective from the community and Thank
You Saskia for introducing me as she
mentioned I'm the international
campaigner for the international
campaign to hold coca-cola accountable
for water abuses in India some of you
may know coca-cola company has many
different bottling plants all across
India and there's they have been
challenged in a lot of different places
in India for denying large numbers of
people particularly farmers particularly
low-income folks of water because gokula
is taking away licking or sucking so
much water from under the ground that
the water tables have fallen drastically
and consequently the farmers and the
people who live around pergolas bottling
plants don't have access to water
anymore including water not only for
farming but including water
for cooking for drinking for cleaning
for bathing just your basic daily needs
so there's been up have a tremendous
campaign led by communities in India to
challenge coca-cola's practices not all
across India but definitely in areas
where coca-cola has located its bottling
plants in water-stressed areas and and
some of them have had just absolutely
tremendous results which I will talk
about but before I get into that I just
wanted to frame sort of where we come
from and I've enjoyed the the
presentations today it's been very very
useful for us however and and you know I
I mean one of the things that we would
like to see more and I when I say we I'm
talking about communities in India
farming communities in India is that as
people here who are presented on you
know new emerging technologies on how to
deal with new crises or emerging crises
or current crisis one of the things we
all need to make sure we do is that we
talk to each other that the communities
are very much included in this process
and this was brought up actually by our
last two speakers their own notion of
environmental justice or even climate
justice is very much actually it came
about as a result of you know people do
an environmental actors own activism or
climate activism but you know having no
connection whatsoever with the people
who were being affected the most by
environmental degradation or climate
crisis unfortunately that situation
still holds true today it has changed it
has improved there is more communication
with social movements around the world
but we need to do better we need to do
more in terms of you know involving
communities around the world especially
those communities who are most impacted
by the climate crisis for example an
environmental degradation for example
especially when we are
proposing or advocating for new ideas on
how to deal with these situations and
this has been one of our biggest
criticisms of the US environmental
movement and the climate movement for
that matter which is one of the reasons
we also say that the climate movement or
the environment moving the United States
has failed in many ways because they
have not been able to engage at the
grassroots level very very effectively
in fact I think all of us know it you
know the BP oil spill it's not a spill
gosh right and this is the biggest
environmental disaster right in the
United States oh where is there Marmol
movement you know the Congress just went
into recess yesterday and they have not
even discussed they have not even
brought up the Senate has not even
considered any new legislation to sort
of have to you know regulate these oil
companies to make sure that something
like this doesn't happen again they're
gone and they're going to only come back
after the elections in November and then
they're only going to meet for two weeks
and then they're going to go home again
and and I've many of us feel that this
is the result you know this is the
result of actually not having enough
people at the grassroots who can who can
let the policymakers know that if you
don't act on this that you're going to
have to pave come election day right and
I think that is something that we all
need to keep in mind for us very much so
as we move forward in in dealing with
the emerging crises around cities around
farming climate has to do with
corporations we feel that there are
certain actors in this global arena who
have tremendous power namely
transnational corporations and of course
there are some individual countries as
well as just the United States and the
European Union block who who wield too
much too much power in these
negotiations for example that Dana was
talking about the the Copenhagen
and and and this is something that we
are very much concerned about as far as
India goes and how we will turn out
essentially what we're seeing is that
regardless of what the government
officials may say about how serious they
are about dealing with the climate
crisis in countries like India or China
at the end of the day if you look at
what they're doing its really business
as usual it's all about promoting in the
case of the United States more corporate
investment from the United States it's
more it's about it's about pushing a
certain model a certain kind of
development a certain kind of lifestyle
right which we live here in the United
States but in fact this is exactly the
lifestyle that has led us to this
climate crisis and this is this
lifestyle that is based primarily on
more consumption it's consume consume
consume and of course the consumption
chain is very many times unsustainable
and so it has led us to this point today
where you know we are like well what are
we going to do you know I mean and you
know even mr. Obama says well you know
in terms of the financial crisis we need
to consume our way out of the crisis
which we think is a completely wrong
message and it's not just about
responsible consumption it is about
consumption and it's about privatization
and private by privatization I mean you
know and somebody had mentioned earlier
today and that in the city of I think
the one of the the eco cities in Korea
that it's about the control of data like
who controls that data is the one you
know who you know isn't in charge right
and because they're making money out of
it and that in fact is what it's all
about it's about corporations and
definitely some countries were jostling
for power but powerful way it's it's
about control it's about having control
so that anything that may happen that
they are the beneficiaries of that and
this is what we're very fearful of in
India as we move forward that a handful
of companies not just the United States
but
around the world including from India
and a handful of governments are
actually dictating our policies in India
and what's going to end up happening is
we're going to start looking more and
more like in some parts of India like
the United States which you know I don't
know if you'd agree but it's not
necessarily a very good thing you know I
mean you to have strip malls and and
these kinds of things all across the
country i think if some if there is
anything the united states has taught us
it ND and europe is which is the path
not to go towards okay and that is
something that we need to learn from so
that was a long context but i do want to
talk about what we're doing with the
kogala company because i think it's very
illustrative of sort of where we're at
and where we're headed and and why it's
rather disastrous the coca-cola company
as you know you know produces all their
products whether it's coca-cola itself
or their orange drinks like Fanta or
bottled water like dasani and in India
and they actually came to india in 1991
so relatively a new entry as far as you
know the world goes because most
countries by 1991 had coca-cola but
india did not and when they came in well
mean what did coca-cola do you know they
obviously looked around for places where
they could manufacture their products in
india and they weren't about it two
different ways and this is typical of
coca-cola the first strategy that
coca-cola used and he uses all over the
place is that they looked at what
already existed in terms of factories
and companies that produce these
beverages these guys and Indians Indian
people we love sweet stuff we have the
highest diabetes rate in the world as
well and you know if you go to our shops
all of our sweet sweet sweet you know
and so we actually had a very active and
a very vibrant indigenous soft drink
industry in India run by Indian
companies and one of the first things
that coca-cola did was it bought those
out it bought out the largest of the
Indian companies and the second thing of
course it did and continues to do is
that it started to build
new bottling plants in India now what
has happened just to make a you know a
long story short is I mean you know when
they build a factory right when they
when they when they even identify a
factory I mean one of the first things
they look at is of course water okay
because when they came into India in
1991 even in two thousand even ten years
later in 2001 it used to take coca-cola
nine liters of water to make one liter
of coca-cola okay so they would take
this perfectly fine fresh water from
under the ground which is the primary
way that they get all their water they
meet all their water needs in India is
from the ground water from you know the
water that is sits in the aquifers under
the ground and and they would put up
these pumps and and as you know it took
him nine liters of water in 2001 to make
one liter of coke hula the question that
we asked and should be asked as well if
it takes you nine to make one what
happens to the other eight right which
is something Coppola does not like to
talk about because the eight liters of
water that does not go into the product
is actually converted into waste water
it is converted into into you know
polluted water because they use the
majority of the water for cleaning for
for he for cleaning the the bottles for
cleaning the machines and cleaning the
floors and they introduce these
chemicals into it and consequently they
they pull you to the most the majority
bass majority water what was going on in
India is that soon after they started
their operations their bottling plants
in different parts of India the people
who live around them started to notice
one thing right and i'm not talking
about one place i'm talking that this
was sort of a pattern that different
communities in different parts of india
within a year or so started to recognize
that suddenly all their wells have
started to go down or even run dry okay
and that the hand water pumps that
people use to meet their water needs
would not work anymore in other words
they would not
bring out water anymore okay you have to
understand we're talking about India
where seventy percent of 70 seventy
percent of our population today still
makes a living related to agriculture so
very agrarian society okay secondly
we're talking about India and that means
that the majority of the population in
India still today does not have piped
drinking water you know taps coming into
their homes instead the vast majority of
people in India even today rely on the
same ground water resource that
coca-cola came in and actually
subsequently Pepsi to today's the same
water resource that the people in India
most people in in the use is what purple
I was tapping into and so when coca-cola
came into these communities many times
what happened was that they took so much
water from under the ground that the
water tables fell in some places that we
have documented they fell about 30 feet
in just two years not 30 feet my friends
is not a small amount of drop ok 30 feet
you know 9.72 meters is one place we
found and there are other stories as
well horror stories I mean this is not
you know this this company as I said I
mean its primary vote this primary raw
material is water how much water does it
take it depends on the planet depends on
the production have capacity in some
parts of India was taking up to 1
million liters of water every day ok so
obviously you know in areas where
there's already the where the water
tables are stressed because it's in a
drought area it's in the desert yes my
friends the coca-cola has built bottling
plants in deserts in India ok we're
already people were having issues
accessing water and here comes his
company saying ok yeah we're going to
build one and so you know doesn't take a
rocket scientist to figure out what
would happen next so that was one thing
that people started to see their water
resources dwindle as a result of
coca-cola coming another second thing
was what happened was and what do you do
when you wells run dry will you dig
deeper into the ground right so that you
tap into you know sometimes 30
deeper and then you will tap into that
depleted aquifer the water table and
they did and when they did you know in
some of the places the water started
flowing again inside coming again the
hand water pump started working again
but immediately almost immediately it
was the women in these areas who noticed
that there was something different about
this order it tasted different it was
not harder you know it you know you
didn't take the soap off like it used to
before it cooked the the lentils and the
rice differently like from before it
used to before they drilled even more
and many of us including the Government
of India and independent agencies got
this water tested and we found that this
water was contaminated and it was
contaminated with what was contaminated
with the same chemicals that coca-cola
used in this factory right in their
factories for cleaning okay because what
kokhono was doing and still does to this
day is that all that wastewater it
generates it would just let it in many
places it would just let it flow
directly outside his bottling plants
just let it out okay and what happens to
that water I'm in one place I went it
was there for one day to day it was a
mango it was a big mango growing area in
Varanasi some of you may know and
there's a lot of mango trees there and
so there's there's water like you know
for three four feet water just sitting
there one day two day three days but yes
after four or five days it disappeared
oh where did it go some of it perhaps
evaporated for the but the vast majority
actually leashed back into the
groundwater and contaminate that
groundwater so this is the story of
coca-cola in India and and you know one
is that they are depriving a lot of
people and I know we're talking about
India some of the villages that we work
with where we have active campaigns
against coca-cola the population of this
village for example in Rajasthan is
10,000 people okay in the United States
to the via town or errors you know but
in India it still remains a village
because of the characteristic of this
area which is largely still very
agrarian and so when we look at the
impacts
when we looked at the tallied of the
impacts it was dramatic I mean we're
talking about tens of thousands of
farmers in India being impacted as a
result of populist operations and and
and you know for farmers yeah I mean and
as I said I mean we're very largely a
great a gradient country if you take
away the water and you poison the
remaining water and the soil that is a
sure recipe for disaster and that is
what the coca-cola company is guilty of
in India it is destroying lives it is
destroying livelihoods and it's
destroying communities across India I
mean I know we know of places that even
scientists have agreed or and what
natural resource experts have agreed
with us that if coca-cola continues to
do business as usual as they're doing
that is to make it you know mindful
water and make products there will be no
community left here in the next 10 to 15
years because there will be no water
left that is terrible anymore this is
how bad the situation is and and so this
is the bad news and I'm going to give
you the good news I mean so there's a
lot of you know and Pepsi Pepsi Co
hasn't had a terribly different record
it is less there are less organic
campaigns against Pepsi operations in
India dan coca-cola but that does not
mean that Pepsi is not the target of
some of these campaigns they in fact are
but in some places you know I mean I'm a
campaigner I'm not a farmer you know and
I choose to do what I do you know I and
I've been doing this for 10 years but in
contrast to the people I work with in
India who are not necessarily
campaigners and what they're doing is
they're fighting for their lives ok
because they are seeing their water
resources dwindle and their farmland
being poisoned and for them it is a
clear matter of fighting for survival
for their wages because many farmers for
example have gone into debt deep into
that because suddenly they find
themselves that there is not enough
water to have successful crop production
so their incomes have reduced depends on
who you speak to which they were you
looking at
sometimes way up to a half of what they
used to make and as it is where we are
india india is economically speaking a
poor country and so for so what we
decided to see was these organic you
know women and and and and farmers
starting to get very angry and always
pointing the finger at that coca-cola's
factory that ever since that fact she
started when our problems started and
they started to organize themselves in
one area in rajasthan this desert place
I told you about that one one one
factory was affecting water Scott water
conditions in 50 different villages in
the radius of that one factory they all
got together started to talk to each
other and and this is where we when we
were also involved and in some places
though the the opposition to coca-cola
and the sophistication of these local
campaigns got so good and so strong that
we shut down coca-cola single largest
bottling plant in March of 2004 in South
India in a village called plaki mark ok
and this this has been you know this as
you know is regarded as a
david-versus-goliath kind of story it
made the front page of New York Times
and Wall Street Journal and stuff well
great but the problem is we have many
more to go and and we have had similar
well we've had significant victories
against coca-cola has been proved for
example by you know the government that
that coca-cola is in fact a responsible
for for water scarcity and pollution as
well and as I said and I as I said I
mean PepsiCo is not very different
either and so these you know these this
is the campaign that I've been working
on we work a lot internationally I work
a lot in Europe in the United States and
Canada we have worked with students not
so much Columbia but at NYU definitely
at Rutgers at University of Michigan
University of Illinois University of
Manchester Sussex University the entire
Norwegian college in university system
to actually remove both
from their campuses as a result of this
disc at the abuses that they are dishing
out in India and it has had a tremendous
impact on this company we also work we
have we used a variety of different
tactics including working with socially
responsible investors shareholder
activism but also we don't shy away from
direct action which was one of the
things that Dana was talking about in
terms of oppositional because we are
very much opposed to what this company
is doing in spite of all the stuff that
we have gotten done and continue to get
done and most importantly our campaign
has never been stronger than it is today
and the reason for that is that now a
lot of these community allegations right
that you know these communities are like
oh is this company have not have been
proved finally you know we we you know
rajendra pachauri some of you may know
he's the chair of the IPCC the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change and he's the guy who shared the
nobel peace prize with Al Gore his group
is called the energy and resources
institute in India is the largest NGO in
India his group did a study because we
forced through University of Michigan
through our campaigns from University of
Michigan and even his group came out and
said that in fact coca-cola needs to
shut down another bottling plant because
the water because it's not sustainable
no so so it's we're very very strong but
you know and and and but we also face a
lot of challenges because we're talking
about coca-cola and Pepsi and and and
this is what you know this is why we
maintain that as you do your work as we
collectively do our work make sure
you're always keeping an eye on these
big companies and what they're up to
because I tell you they're not up to
very good because as far as they're
concerned it's not about saving the
world or saving the climate it's not not
what drives them in fact that is not
within their mandate I know some of you
may have been following the the whole
you know notion around corporate social
responsibility and on some companies are
coming out really strong with csr and
coca-cola is one of them but csr you
know or corporate social responsibility
is not the
duty of these corporations in fact they
would they would be in a sense breaking
the law if they were to go out and make
saving the world as their primary
mission because their primary mission to
their shareholders is to maximize
profits and what we're seeing in India
is that many companies not just
coca-cola Pepsi as well are using these
crises these emerging crisis whether it
be with water and access to water in
India is definitely a crisis climate
change is is something that plays you
know apart but it's not just climate
we've had a emerging water crisis for
many years because of irresponsible
water use you know say bye-bye-bye
farmers yeah but still but but but by
industry as well and and these companies
now we see are positioning themselves in
this game because they understand that
in countries like India and China and
these are very big countries I'm sure
all of you recognize I mean we are
together forty percent of the world's
population and we have we are on a very
rapid you know growth right a trajectory
of growth but you have to understand it
when it comes to fresh water we are
India and China we are forty percent of
the world's population but we only have
access to seven percent of the world's
freshwater resources and and and as we
grow whether it's it's whether its
energy energy is where water intensive
you need a lot of water no matter
whether it's cool you know thermal coal
fired power plant or whether its nuclear
energy alright which you know I mean
which they are pushing into India as
well you need and so we are reaching our
limits and there is indeed a crisis in
fact BBC or actually the BBC reported
yesterday but the nature magazine has a
wonderful news story on this on this new
water crisis that's facing India and
China and the rest of the world as well
that just this is their current issue
and as a result of this what we're
seeing is that many of these companies
are trying to get control over vast
amounts of water resources in countries
like India and China but also in you
know the continent of Africa and differ
part of Africa and they do they're doing
this in different ways I mean they're
working with the international monetary
fund they're working with the World Bank
they're working with the United States
government they're definitely working
with Bill Clinton who and and and and
Hillary Clinton who happened to be very
very close friends with coca-cola it
seems and any chance they get they are
promoting coca-cola you know to go into
different countries including places
like and then you know places like Haiti
after after the earthquake the
devastating earthquake you know Bill
Clinton announced this new projects or
that cool cool i can go into a tea and
help them plant mango trees so that they
can make mango drinks for the rest of
the world and this is what we call
disaster capitalism you know you take
you you look at you know what is
disastrous and you try to take advantage
of advantage meaning how you can profit
the most from it and we're seeing this
trend over and over again and this is
something that we very much reject I
have and the other alongside this you
know we see that companies like
coca-cola are also very aggressively
positioning themselves as through
through the use of public relations has
this very green company you know
coca-cola I mean if you if you go to
their website and and and and look at
what they have to say about water and if
you didn't know the address and didn't
see their logo you'd think it would be a
group like ours who's working on
conserving water who's you stuff your
reading I mean it's just you know if you
go to the way they're there and they
have a museum in Atlanta brand new app
world it's about three years old now you
know it's like water is life you know I
mean these are the kind of things that
we have used you know and they have
mastered this they've hired an
anthropologist to head up there their
water program in around the world and he
talks from that anthropology stuff but I
must say you know because I'm at
Columbia University here Pepsi is no
different Pepsi and Indra know either
CEO sauna on a fast track to suddenly
become the saviors of the world by two
things one is that there are such a
green company
hey they're not I mean they take water
away from people and and so does
coca-cola secondly Pepsi is on a fast
track to become a nutrition company okay
this is a company that sells us frito
lay chips ok this is the company that
sells and places aggressively along with
coca-cola these high sugar products in
our schools that hasn't led to the
United States having an obesity epidemic
today which many many people experts
included they look at the role of these
junk food companies at the center of it
so it comes as a sort of bug you know I
the world we were not very happy that
the Earth Institute the Earth Institute
here at Columbia University has taken a
grant from PepsiCo foundation of six
million dollars over three years to do
what 22 to promote sustainable use of
water around the world for the next day
yes give me a break I mean this is
nothing more than a green washed
exercise and now they're using a
university with a good reputation like
Columbia University to go ahead and do
this and not only that I mean so they
have what do they do and and their focus
is not the entire world even though they
say world but guess where their focus is
no surprise India China South Africa
right and Brazil who are these countries
we are the emerging economies these are
the countries where coca-cola and
pepsico and companies like that want to
get more control over not just the water
resources but they want every Indian to
be drinking you know the thing about
coca-cola and pepsico could aztech
coca-cola the average Indian today
drinks about four cans of coca-cola ok
in a year ok in the United States it's
about 380 so what do you think these
these PepsiCo and coca-cola want they
want every Indian and every Chinese and
every Brazilian right to become like the
United States and Mexico Mexico is
number one in terms of
sumption of Gokula in the world but not
surprisingly mexico has some of the
highest obesity rate in the world and so
does the United States okay where we
know I mean this is we have a huge huge
problem here and so the other aspect in
addition to sort of getting the water
resources the other aspect of these
companies what they are trying very much
to do is to control our market places
because as the end you know they're
losing their sales as a result of people
becoming more nutritionally savvy in
countries like the United States and in
Germany and places they're actually
seeing not a rapid decline in sales but
definitely is stagnant yeah and in some
countries is going down but not not too
rapidly but they know it's going to go
it's good they're their products are
under attack in the United States even i
live in Berkeley California even our
little Schwarzenegger of poly Arnold
Schwarzenegger is the man who signed the
bill that banned the sale of coca-cola
and Pepsi n and carbonated sugar
beverages from all our high schools and
down okay and so I mean there is this
huge awareness and so they know that so
what do they want to do they want to
take their products to places like India
and China and our out what we say is
that look if junk food whether it be
your potato chips and stuff or whether
whether it be your carbonated beverages
hi sugar beverages if it's bad for the
health of Americans people and people in
Europe why is it any good for us in
India and China I mean if it is just
like the tobacco companies that right i
mean this is what they once they got
regulated here they move their markets
to China or they try to very much so so
if this comes it comes for us and we're
not very happy to see why columbia
university is actually engaged in this
green washing exercise with PepsiCo and
so if anybody actually is interested in
working with us and we do this work a
lot I mean we always we do a lot of
monitoring we also do a lot of advocacy
education and in india we call which you
didn't have on your list is education
Indians love to a jet right so because
if you get agitated about something
which we are about coca-cola and Pepsi
then we get then we agitate about it
which means a whole range of things but
definitely you know direct action but
but if people here are interested you
should definitely be in touch with us
because we have been in touch with
PepsiCo because of some outrageous
statements that both coca-cola and Pepsi
have made and I'm going to end with that
I mean that you know the public
relations is a big part of what we have
to fight with and coca-cola and PepsiCo
have tremendous amount of resources that
they spend on public relations coca-cola
company for example last year 2009 we
think it's it spent about nine billion
dollars just in advertising there is no
company that comes close to advertising
to putting so much money into
advertising and you take that ya know
and and and what can you know there's
not a whole lot that we can do but a lot
of this this this is also about you know
forming alliances with universities like
Columbia but you're not alone is Yale
University as well is a part of this of
a part of a separate initiative but it's
also about manufacturing a certain
message that may not have any basis in
reality and we're seeing this very much
for example Cola claims that in India it
is a water neutral company coca-cola is
saying it has no impact whatsoever on
water resources in India and when Pepsi
found out perhaps he said hey hey hey we
can do one better so Pepsi just
announced a month ago that they have a
positive water balance in India in other
words as a result of their operations in
India Indians get more water than we
already have which made us think like
wait a minute if there's drought anybody
drought let's build a coca-cola robot a
pepsi bottling plant right this is
exactly what they're suggesting this is
the extent to which they will go and
unfortunately this is the
stand to which Columbia University will
actually allow them to go I don't buy
that so hopefully we can work together
and we can come up with something
together okay thank you very much
oh thank you